we are back it's your host stephen lim
driving
but also we have another host driving
andrew hill nicki
adam whose car are you in i think i'd
rather be in stephen's car
what dang get right driver
and why are we in two cars today you
might ask it's because
we're going on a picnic that's right
today i'm worth it
we're going to be trying three picnics
at three drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it at its price
that's why we're all driving separately
is because we're all
meeting at our picnic location picnics
are having a little bit of resurgence
right now it's a great way to
meet up with people to dine outside in a
responsible socially distance manner and
this will be taking place over
three days whoa whoa whoa whoa we're
about to picnic for three straight days
is this like picnic chella sure our
three picnics are not
all strictly picnic specific food but
they will be foods that
travel well and are convenient to eat
outdoors
all right andrew what is the first
restaurant that we're going to be
enjoying today first we're going to see
manager jana
at jengalov hots an armenian restaurant
that specializes
in one dish only and the name of the
dish is
jungle of hots
drinkyal of hot the translation is bread
with herbs
it's a national dish we have few
restaurants
in capital of armenia yerevan same name
same dish here in glendale we have a lot
of americans who love it
as vegan food the dough is very simple
it's a flour
water salt and the filling we have
usually 12 different types of herbs
whatever we do in armenia it's exactly
same what we do here
we don't use any machine everything goes
by hand
and to open the door very thin it's not
too easy
that's how this restaurant was made to
show customers
the process of making the dish and i
like it i appreciate it because the
dough
is so thin it's not oven it just
all flat stuff it takes like 30-40
seconds one and another side
and it's ready i have a lot of customers
friday saturday sunday people take like
10
20 breads by going outside because it's
nice and easy you don't get dirty
non-greasy
people who grew up in armenia i grew up
with this dish
i have a customers who come say oh it's
so good you open
here it brings back memories so it's a
simple
and it's a healthy dish
we're back picnic season been a while
since i've seen you in person
you've gotten stronger i have thanks for
noticing hey you got a little buffer
today
not just today we have a
yogurt drink i've had like the asian
yogurt drinks it's gonna taste like that
you think i'm not sure i've never seen
this before
cheers
wow i thought i was gonna get milk or
yogurt and i got neither
it really has the same sort of like
mouth drying
and puckering as greek yogurt we're
starting off with something very simple
oh but this is perfect picnic food it
comes in a box
you can pick it up with one hand
[Music]
it's delicious it's really good reminds
me of the chive dumpling we had in
taiwan
so dense with green vegetables you know
what is surprising about this
it's kind of juicy in a meat kind of way
to be honest when i saw it i was like oh
i kind of feel like i'm going to be
disappointed when i bite into that just
cause i'm so preconditioned to like
order things with meat but this is very
satisfying we should have a
picnic ability like how much does it
picnic
reclined position one-handed does it
picnic there's picnics this picnics
there's also dessert it's just dessert
with walnuts and honey
oh my goodness look at the inside
this is a fire hose of deliciousness
into your mouth i think this might be
the most comfortable we've ever been
ask me about picnic steve you picnic oh
i picnic adam do you pick nick
we're now in our second day of
picnicking now on day two we're really
getting into
the elongated picnic mode but before we
get there
picnic fact woven baskets were the
earliest vessel
used to transport food because they were
light and versatile
but also sturdy if there's anything this
fact says about humans is that we
were born to picnic weaving in general
is i think is one of the most impressive
inventions the idea that you're taking a
strand
and turning it into something with
structure
and strength i don't know if prehistoric
andrew would have been able to figure
that one out
i am most certainly sure that
prehistoric andrew
would not have figured out weaving we're
now on our way to see
jihi at perilla la which is not a
restaurant but it's a
to go only business that sells
korean banchon and this particular
business comes recommended to us by
our friend sorry a baby squirrel was
just walking so slowly across the road
i always slow down for animals so
perilla la was actually recommended to
us by
friend of the show riya really used to
work
with jihy rye said oh you're looking for
picnic foods you gotta go to perilla la
it's
i mean during pandemic i have a lot of
time to
think and i always have this idea of
making
korean bunsen with californian produce
bansan is a
little korean side dishes that can be
eaten with rice so i grew up in korea
my grandma started a restaurant very
similar model
they are known for their bantam i used
to work at rossi canyon
i learned a lot about how to treat great
produce
basically it's combination of what i've
learned at the restaurant
with the flavor that i grew up with i go
to santa monica farmers market
i have a relationship with farmers i
always check with them
and they just tell me what's good in the
season i do
marinated okra that's like one of the
most popular menu
okra is not traditionally korean
ingredient
i think it would be nice to add a char
flavor and
i use the vinegary soy sauce overnight
and i also have an eggplant dish
which is from my family that they
actually use it even
right now at their restaurant so the
only difference i use
there on the chili and my mom probably
used korean chili
and nori chip it takes over a day
i used two nori sheets together and then
sweet rice porridge
i spread it on top of it and then i
dehydrate and then become
like dry chips a lot of my bunsen
it looks really simple but i have to
wait
like i ferment a lot of stuff it's
amazing to see
how flavor changes the good thing about
my food
you can pick up and then live in your
fridge a lot of
my guests they told me like oh yeah i'm
picking this up to camping
and i was like oh that's actually a good
idea because
it holds well i'm also learning because
it's not
just about cooking i have to talk to a
customer they have a lot of questions i
have to post
on instagram i started cooking at my old
apartment
and there's no light i bought the white
box and i took the photo from my iphone
it's all like learning process and i i
feel grateful
to do that
[Music]
picnic day two day two when it's a
picnic day it's a great day
prilla if you remember our first time
eating on this show
korean barbecue that's right perilla a
type of leaf
shall we napkin so jihi's given us
a bunch of different dishes i think we
should start with one of her favorites
the okra cheers cheers that is not
okra it tastes like the word
barbecue the delicious char when you
bite it
it's like cooling apart and falling
apart in your mouth kind of like the way
that barbecue does yeah
i'm honestly shocked by it what did you
do to the okra what you're tasting
is time and not t-h-y-m-e okay chip
break
chip break oh oh my gosh
oh bam bam
hey chicharron shut up this chip is in
town now
it's a seaweed chicharron yeah this
picnic's real hard
so this is cabbage layered with perilla
leaf
that is delightful i mean it's really
pretty much exactly
sauerkraut you know what you do next
what this egg looking thing that i think
is egg
i mean i never thought i would eat an
omelet on a picnic it's not just an
omelette though it's like a crepe
these green beans are catching my eye
each of these you can just grab very
easily with chopsticks just go boom
done all right so i want to go to this
one next it's like cucumbers
like kimchi like pickled is that
pineapple i think it's melon picnic
picnic yo yo
yo okay shut it down this is the best
one that's got everything going for it
it's pickled it's a little spice behind
it let's go to the eggplant
cheers stephen here if you like eggplant
this
is like the most eggplanty eggplant you
can eat in your life you want to take a
real trip go back to the okra
house back to where we started and this
is how you picnic
around and around you go so like what
you're saying is that this food
picnics this food picnics
[Music]
okay picnic day three and stephen and i
are just along for the ride in the back
because at our last picnic we're gonna
be enjoying some delicious wine
so before our last picnic picnic fact
most historians agree that the word
picnic is derived from the 17th century
word
picnic though at the time it was used to
describe
a social gathering that was more like a
potluck where everyone would contribute
a different food item by 1802 the term
in the activity had made its way to
london where a group of francophiles
people who love french culture
established a picnic society at which
they were known to eat drink and put on
small
shows and performances i love how it was
upgraded
to a dinner and a show outdoors it also
feels like it was more of an
outdoorsman's kind of club have you ever
been part of a food club
i have not i guess this show is a little
bit of a food club all of our millions
of viewers we're all part of the worth
it club this is our own
worth it society wait now i feel like
it's a cult speaking of picnic society
we're on our way to our last location
now
we're going to see chef curtis stone at
his new pop-up
at the grove called picnic society so at
picnic society they have a number of
curated baskets the basket that we're
gonna have
features an assortment of charcuterie
that comes from
chef curtis's other restaurant gwen i
love how they're paying homage to the
original picnic society
kind of like fanny packs back in style
baby
i'm curtis stone and we're in picnic
society which is a pop-up by gwen gwen's
a butcher shop
and a dining room and the butcher shop
is sort of the heartbeat of the dining
room we pull together a beautiful
selection of meats game wagyu and we
make all of our own chakrutari what we
were seeing
at gwen was a lot of people were coming
in and buying things that would be sort
of ideal for a picnic we sort of just
got a little playful with the idea and
thought we'd do it as a business and
then we got the opportunity to come over
here to the grove and do a pop-up
restaurant so here we are we've
a beautiful big patio here at the grove
and then we have a terrace up here on
the first floor which we call the
backyard it's really cozy but still very
individual you know when you think about
a picnic it's actually a beautiful way
to dine because you really linger you
graze on the food
we've got beautiful blankets lawn games
anything that you could imagine to
create the perfect picnic is in this
building so there's a few ways you can
go about ordering your picnic basket you
can either build your own
or you can let us build it for you so
the gwen basket really celebrates
everything about gwen the big
highlighter is a beautiful selection of
cured meats teresa's an incredible
butcher and she runs the the butcher
shop over there at gwen she's also
learned the charcuterie very very
closely she's
studied it she's moved to italy wagyu
brusola brussola is air-dried beef
and we sourced it from blackmore's wagyu
beef production in australia a couple of
years ago we actually
went to blackmore farms in australia to
interview
uh mr black dave itself yeah and if it
was a couple of years ago there's a
chance you saw the steer that you're
gonna taste today
it's a beautiful product to start with
and hopefully we make it even more
special
and what goes so brilliantly with cured
meats is wonderful cheeses and then all
of the things that you'd expect to eat
really well with that dried mascartel
grapes some crackers some paste we make
a chicken liver parfait
i learned how to make it with marco
pierre white when i cooked in europe and
it reminds me of my childhood growing up
in tough restaurants we make beautiful
olive oil and
sea salt sticker bread dom is one of our
incredible pastry chefs here and he
bakes that stack of bread
as well as making all the beautiful
sweet things that you can come and find
chocolate chunk cookies so we get big
chunks of velarana chocolate i like to
think the cookie's just there to hold
the chocolate chunks together picnic
society we like to say you bring your
own weather to the picnic it's very true
you know like a picnic is meant to be a
time that you spend with people you care
about and it's not meant to be rushed
[Music]
i'm extremely comfortable it's not just
this deluxe blanket that we've gotten
just for this occasion what is this
this is made by trilby nelson and you
can buy these at picnic society because
you can buy everything you need
for a picnic look at this box it looks
like a briefcase
you ready to pop it open i'm gonna pop
it three two one
okay so we opted to also buy a bottle of
wine
and we have a nice greek rose roses do
that really incredible job of still
being like but they can hold up to that
beautiful cured meat
and it matches my blanket come on cheers
stephen
to three picnics
[Music]
yo that's nice whoa
i just i just saw the chocolate chip
cookie that that's for dessert steven
yeah i know but it's a thing you can
start with it it's pigmented
yeah true don't try to throw your rules
on me i'm starting with a chocolate chip
cookie you want to start with a cookie
we'll start with cookies oh my gosh
you can't go wrong with chocolate chip
cookies it's almost like a chocolate
panini now let's get to some savory food
i say we kick off the party with a
little
parfait oh man that's good bread look at
this
i don't think i've ever spread chicken
on bread before
[Music]
my hearing just cut out for a second
okay so let's
do cheese next so i love a cheese that's
just
kind of like butter so this one was a
bloomy rind sheep milk cheese
i love cheese we got some dried grapes
here so in australia you remember the
museum muscadel that's wine produced
from this type of grape
these grapes are crazy i think it's time
for a posture change
i'm leaning over steven are you seeing
the sunset right now look at these
clouds look at the mountains
it's time for some meat i think so
so good it has this incredible like
jamminess to it
it's borderline fruit leather there's
duck spectacular
so that's the darkest one this duck is
the best bacon i've ever had
i want a pickle now because i've had a
lot of really fatty meats
pickle cheers so steven
does this meal picnic this picnics and i
could do that because i'm outside
[Music]
that was a picnic trilogy i've really
developed a new appreciation for the
picnic i think i'm going to be
picnicking a lot more in the future
it's time to tell me which picnic was
the most worth it at its given price
point
i think all three of these truly
picnicked i think my winner is gonna be
perilla la because i had no concern
about taking my time with that food and
i think for me
that's what's best about a picnic you
know i really love the picnic society
and those
meats were just perfect but the question
today is does it picnic and yes while
the pitting society does picnic and
while perilla la does picnic jenga love
hots
they really picnic you can grab and go
you can bring it to a hike you can bring
it to the beach
adam who's your worth it winner all
right that does it for worth it picnics
i'm picnicked out see you next week when
we do worth it savory pies
[Music]
you